[Música]
[Aplausos]
hace unos días me pasó algo muy curioso
que os quiero contar
estaba paseando por la calle y de pronto
un señor me dijo tiene usted ahora
le di la hora y proseguir con mi camino
me metí a una cafetería y pedí mi café
con leche pero el camarero no me escuchó
estaba distraído con algo que os contaré
al final
café con leche por favor le insistí
nuevamente
mientras me estaba tomando el café me
llamaron por teléfono no tenía
memorizado el número pero de inmediato
reconocí por el timbre de voz a mi amiga
de málaga y no solamente reconocí quién
era sino que además intuía que estaba
muy contenta y efectivamente tener
razones para ello pues se acababa de
doctoral
por la universidad carlos tejero de
madrid
curiosamente me di cuenta que en todos
estos casos no hemos guiado por la voz
por el oído y con elementos propiamente
musicales
la frecuencia de me sirvió para ver que
me estaban haciendo una pregunta la
intensidad fue necesaria para que me
escuchará el camarero
a mi amiga la reconocí por el timbre de
voz y su alegría por el tiempo la
velocidad de hablar
frecuencia intensidad tiempo y tempo a
velocidad son elementos propiamente
musicales y esto es normal somos tan
musicales como comunicativos
el lenguaje y música nos define y en
este sentido nuestra especie es única
desde que nacemos estamos marcados ya
por el sonido con este llanto que nos
trae a la vida y nuestra voz forma parte
de nuestro adn somos lo que somos por lo
que se ve y por lo que se oye
si nos damos cuenta estamos rodeados
continuamente de expresiones musicales
decimos
vivir en armonía
ir al unísono poner un contrapunto son
expresiones que no son familiares a
todos del ámbito musical pero además la
música nos rodea continuamente en un
anuncio publicitario en un espectáculo
de circo con una consulta médica para
hacernos más llevadera la espera
reconocemos muchas veces la procedencia
de un ganador olímpico por el himno en
la ceremonia de entrega de medallas y la
champions se identifica con música de
haendel
no hay fiesta sin música y el cine la
necesita para guiarnos en la trama para
ubicarnos en tiempo y en espacio
y también para etiquetar a su personaje
[Música]
os imaginais otro escenario que no sea
la selva de malú y de mul y yo
francamente no verdaderamente cuanto nos
transmite tan solo unos compases
pero de todas las conexiones que se
pueden establecer con la música a mí me
fascina especialmente una la que
mantiene la música y la poesía
la poesía nace con la música en nace y
vive con ella los poemas se cantaban se
contaban y los juglares eran tantos
poetas como músicos
esta relación lógicamente dura hasta hoy
y es evidente en una canción
el poeta suministra la letra y el músico
finaliza la tarea dándole envoltura
musical pero cuanto más es fascinante la
relación de la poesía con la música
instrumental la que no tiene palabras
vamos a hacer una especie de viaje de
ida y vuelta desde el verso al
pentagrama del pentagrama al verso a
través de cuatro fórmulas de mediaciones
la primera de ellas es la inspiración
que inspira una obra musical que inspira
un poema realmente puede ser cualquier
cosa
un terreno bastante difícil de explorar
y bastante hermético
gerardo diego nos dejó
por escrito su pasión por chopin y lo
transmitió en su libro ofrenda a chopin
pero todavía más sugerente el viaje
inverso lo que va del poema a la música
muchas veces esta inspiración se
manifiesta en los propios títulos de las
obras por ejemplo en bases poéticos de
enrique granados o en dolor a poesía
musical de felipe pedrell otras veces
son versos estrofas o incluso poemas
completos los que antecede la partitura
musical a modo de guía para el
intérprete a modo de inspiración para el
pianista y así no los dejo por ejemplo
luis leandro mariani un compositor
sevillano en su obra el florero
la segunda fórmula de mediación musical
es el sonsonete la melodía es la fórmula
más básica la más presente y la más
recurrente está atravesando autores y
obras de todos los tiempos
garcilaso por ejemplo recurrió a la
repetición del aire para imitar el
correr del agua con canto acordado al
rumor que sonaba y curiosamente este
efecto del correr del agua tiene un
paralelo perfecto en el piano a través
de acordes arpegiado rápidos como nos
muestra eduardo con en esta obra que se
titula rain farc viaje por el rey
[Música]
la onomatopeya es contagiosa estimulante
es patrimonio del poeta pero también del
músico el canto del cuco era la rúbrica
sonora del compositor joaquín rodrigo
atraviesa su célebre concierto de
aranjuez pero también está presente en
esta pastoral para piano
[Música]
ahora os pido atención para el siguiente
fragmento que os voy a tocar el
zapateado dejo aquí en la regla y con
ella
con este zapateado vamos a iniciar la
tercera fórmula el ritmo
no
[Música]
a
como veis es una pieza alegre lleno de
vida de vitalidad y en gran parte esta
alegría se contagia por este ritmo
ternario constante
el ritmo realmente es todo el ritmo está
en nuestros latidos del corazón está en
nuestro caminar en la cadencia al hablar
quién oído alguna vez por la calle y ha
ido andando al ritmo que marcaba la
música que escuchaba por los auriculares
pues bien este ritmo ternario puede
tener también su réplica poética y la
vamos a ver en un poema genial del poeta
miguel hernández eterna sombra
yo que creí que la luz era mía
precipitado en la sombra me veo ascuas
solar se verá la alegría y cine de
espuma de luz de deseo
la puerta fórmula de adecuación musical
y poética
sería la estructura la forma
para mucho artista en la primera digamos
que la forma el andamiaje el esqueleto
es el primer planteamiento que se hace
en muchos artistas a la hora de hacer su
obra de creación hay géneros afines como
por ejemplo el villancico o la
seguidilla la seguidilla se caracteriza
por ser una estrofa muy popular con
versos alternado de siete y cinco
sílabas
lógicamente un poeta tan musical tan
popular como garcía lorca no podía dejar
de escribir una seguidilla como la que
vemos en este poema de los peregrinos
hacia roma caminan dos peregrinos para
que los case el papá porque son primos
y esta seguidilla tiene también su
paralelo es música y nos lo deja de
forma digamos muy muy disimulada y muy
escondida
el gran músico isaac albéniz en su
castilla seguidilla
vamos a ver como alterna esta frase de 7
y 5 partes
2 3 4 5 6 7 2 3 4
[Música]
pero claro el maestro no estaría
satisfecho con esta interpretación voy a
hacerla ahora como creo que al maestro
le hubiera gustado
[Música]
y
bien pues con esta última forma la
adecuación la estructura llegamos al
final de nuestra charla pero no me
quiero marchar sin antes revelar el
secreto inicial os comenté que el
camarero estaba distraído no me oyó
cuando le pidió el café pues bien estaba
distraído porque estaba canturreando una
canción
una de esas canciones que creo conoce
medida españa en las otras medias
también sigo la canción era caminante no
hay camino con poemas de antonio machado
y música de man joan manuel serrat
qué bello poema el de don antonio
machado le dije al camarero y el
camarero muy sorprendido me miró me dijo
señora no hay marchado ese rato
y yo pensé
realmente cuánta gente conoce poemas los
cantan a diario y ni siquiera son
conscientes de ello pero lo más
sorprendente era que posiblemente lo
estaba haciendo de la forma que más le
hubiera gustado don antonio machado
puesto en música
[Música]
y es que realmente
las palabras nunca se podrán separar de
la música ni tampoco la música de las
palabras muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]